well with so many businesses taking that
big financial hit
people are still trying to figure out
new ways to make an income
eight sports kevin martin joining us
with more on a familiar face in the
golden age community
who really needs our help hi there kevin
yeah brian a familiar face is
right and quite possibly even more
recognizable is his voice
cornell johnson who was garnered the
nickname golden pipes instantly became a
fan favorite and the most frequent
national anthem singer for the golden
knights games at t-mobile arena
and yesterday golden knights golden
pipes excuse me reaching out to those
fans on social media for a little help
he sent out these series of tweets
letting his followers know that he was
currently out of work
and that he just had to take his car to
the shop he went on to say he absolutely
will do manual labor and even teach
voice lessons distance or over zoom the
number of responses he got was
incredible
he said a number of people reached out
to him about odd jobs and even some
people who said
they didn't have any work for him but
just wanted to help in fact when i spoke
to him earlier today on zoom
he was at someone's house house taking
down halloween decorations
golden pipe says this is just another
example of how great the las vegas
community is
what didn't surprise me about it was
overwhelming sense of community
um and i mean that was
evident in 2017 um
when we all came together after october
1
and you know that just thinking about
that
and and what this city means
to its residents and the the links that
they are willing to go through to help
one of their own is just absolutely
phenomenal
and if you want to help golden pipes in
any way he said the best way to reach
him is at his email
which you can also see below me on the
screen vegas
golden pipes gmail.com